[Music]
everyone had an okay Valentine's Day the
other day did you get another one
I hear booing it's the people sitting
alone or moving
speaking of romance the u.s. rate of
interracial marriages is it an all-time
high
I know I know from experience because my
wife is white and I'm super white
I'm like what the f is wrong guy
people think I'm ill people on the
street said you want bone marrow when I
walk yes Nicholas tough day for Newt
Gingrich yesterday did you hear about
this he's in town yesterday Newt
Gingrich's campaign bus got a flat tire
in the gay section of Hollywood yeah
yeah gank Gingrich says he wishes his he
had known this before he went around
asking men for a quick jack and a pump
here's the gamepad check the rim while
you're down there
[Applause]
I don't know whether to fire you or give
you a medal you can do both yeah all
right what's going on in the United
States this is new stick this is crazy
in the United States there are nearly
1.8 million dead people who were still
registered to vote yeah dead people were
still registered to vote yeah as a
matter of fact they're the group that's
most passionate about Mitt Romney they
just may be yeah especially they've been
dead for more than 100 years they're
crazy about him he's very big with the
moldering yes okay an Arizona lawmaker
wants to make it a crime for teachers to
curse in front of their students that
would be a crime yeah
Arizona teachers are upset because their
favorite part of the day was telling
their students pop quiz heads
[Applause]
[Music]
just call mom and tell her not to watch
tonight all right I won't my mothers
Edith bunker you know one thing that you
hear about a lot these days everyone's
talking about it why is it that China
seems to have a leg up on the United
States these days okay why are the
Chinese people so dominant you know why
is their country so dominant well we try
to provide some answers in a segment we
call why China is kicking our ass reason
number 929
[Applause]
[Music]
actually I take that as a sign that we
are coming back strong so we're willing
to hurl our face into a fan right
I trust us can-do attitude exactly
grit determination